LFI qui a fait des déclarations qui
n'ont pas été appréciées pour le moins
de tout le monde après et bien ce qui
s'est passé au prochorient ce weekend
euh des déclarations mettant en gros
pour faire schématique sur le même plan
ce que les agressions du Hamas les
opérations terroristes du Hamas et puis
l'attitude d'Israël dans cette région du
monde est-ce que euh la gauche et la
nupess VA résist
à cette espèce de secousse de ce séisme
qui est né de ces déclarations écoutez
il faut d'abord se poser la question de
savoir si la nupes préexistait à cette
attaque terroriste qui é intervenu ce
weekend c'està dire que la nupes était
déjà en état de morts quasiment
programmé en raison des européennes par
l'explosion des listes on en a parlé
beaucoup ici déjà sur des affaires de
politique interne en France évidemment
les déclarations de J Mélenchon celle
aujourd'hui de Mathilde Panau qui est la
présidente du groupe des insoumis euh à
l'Assemblée et qui a refusé de qualifier
le Hamas de groupes terroriste justement
a encore fait monter la tension elle a
été obligée ces dernières heures euh de
de de modifier pour essayer de trouver
cette espèce d'équilibre qu'il cherche
voilà à établir entre
justement entre les de les deux les deux
euh et et elle être empêtré en fait on
voit bien qu'ils sont dans une situation
complètement ils se sont vraiment isolés
y compris avec le NPA mais en revanche
ça c'est le Nouveau Parti
Anticapitaliste si vous voulez on va on
va on va les écouter un petit peu pour
se remettre un peu dans le dans le dans
le paysage j'ai une position qui est
ferme qui est claire et qui ne suppose
pas la moindre atténuation de ma part
simplement je vous dis une chose c'est
que parfois l'Union est un combat
parfois effectivement il faut faire
respecter une parole et moi ce que je
veux faire aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
mal'aligner sur une position qui ne
serait pas la mienne c'est de faire en
sorte que toute la gauche rejoigne une
position qui est une position de raison
et de responsabilité le terrorisme n'est
à aucun moment
acceptable il ne peut pas y avoir la la
moindre ambiguïté vis-à-vis de la France
insoumise or les alliances et elles
existent toujours dans le cadre de la
anupest Jérôme GCH pour qui j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié de tendresse et qu'un
garçon courageux mais il était favorable
à une liste d'union au moment des
européennes euh euh avec euh les filles
je crois que ça ne sera plus le cas et
tant mieux plus d'ctualité il il doit y
avoir un cordon sanitaire à l'égard de
la France insoumise et de ses positions
de la violence de son discours Judi euh
on entend manuel Vals mais qui n'est
plus au Parti socialiste et on entend
Boris valallot cet après-midi qui dit
certes mais il faut garder la coalition
et il faut rester dans euh la coalition
de l'anupè absolument euh d'ailleurs je
trouve que la déclaration que vous venez
de passer d'Olivier fort montre qu'il
n'a pas du tout envie de quitter la
nuupesse qui est en fait sa garantie de
survie électorale lui particulièrement
fort là où il est élu il doit son siège
à la nupes il y a une étiquette nupes
sur son fauteuil de députés mais je
trouve qu'il y a il y a même une une
question intéressante à se poser en AM
de la survie de laanupè c'est est-ce que
le groupe la France a soumise est-ce que
le parti la France a
soumise soumis à des tensions énormes va
y résister parce qu'on parle de Mathilde
panneau et de sa position mais plusieurs
tendances se sont dessinées ces derniers
jours et même ces dernières heures entre
Daniel obono qui a rédigé le
communiqué qui a fait scandale à juste
titre et François Ruffin par exemple qui
lui qui lui a
absolument
condamné les attaques terroristes en
prononçant le mot sans aucune gêne et en
l'assumant Arthur oui est-ce que ce que
dit Judith est-ce que la la France a
soumise va pouvoir rester unie je crois
que je vais d'abord repartir si vous me
permettez de votre question d'origine
qui était la gauche de gouvernement
peut-elle cabit
continuer de de cohabiter avec LFI au
sein de l'ANUP et puis ensuite on se
demandera si la LFI de gouvernement peut
cohabiter à la deè à la deuxème
questionah est-ce qu'au sein de LFI il y
a une une LFI plus contestataire et une
LFI qui est amené à rejoindre la gauche
de
gouvernement si j'osais je vous dirais
que on verra l'avenir nous dira si ce
schisme aura lieu en attendant il y a
d'abord un schisme qui devrait avoir
lieu qui pourrait avoir lieu c'est celui
entre la gauche les gauches de
gouvernement h elles sont trois elles
sont plutôt deux et demi c'est le parti
socialiste euh les écologistes EV qui
changeront d'ailleurs bientôt de nom et
puis de temps en temps le Parti
communiste euh LFI est venu se greffer à
cet ensemble là pourquoi parce qu'il les
trois ont fait un score désastreux à la
présidentielle rappelons-le hein le PS
c'est 1,75 % je crois je parle sous le
contrôle de Sophie les communistes c'est
deux fois plus dit comme ça c'est
extraordinaire mais c'est 3 % et puis
les écologistes c'est moins de 5 % quand
on sait que écologie est aujourd'hui un
enjeu capital donc il y a ces trois
parties dit de gouvernement qui sont
faiblissimes dans le paysage politique
et puis il y a Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a
fait on le rappelle 22 % pourquoi
j'insiste là-dessus parce que c'est ça
qui aujourd'hui est la matrice de cette
Nupe c'est que Mélenchon il a réussi le
tour de force de tordre le bras aux
trois autres parties de la gauche de
gouvernement et qu'aujourd'hui ils se
sont en effet soumis à la France
insoumise et c'est un petit peu une une
sorte de perfusion dont ils savent que
s'ils se l'arrache leur chance de de vie
ou de survie sont quasi nuls et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il a conscience de ça et c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il vous voyez que toute
la gauche s'est élevée contre lui il n'a
pas bouger d'une virgule dans sa
position sur le sujet alors martial
foucco il y a quand même un paradoxe en
fonction de ce que vient de dire
d'ailleurs Arthur à l'instant et d'une
certaine façon Judite c'est que
effectivement si on les prend hors de
l'anupes c'est communistes c'estes
socialistes voir ses écologistes il sont
plutôt assez faibles et néanmoins on
prend les élections européenne les
projections en sondage qui sont
aujourd'hui disponibles et on s'aperçoit
que séparés ils sont plus forts que uni
comment vous expliquez ça oui c'est ça
peut paraître paradoxal mais il y a pas
de surprise en fait ce qui va se passer
pour les élections européennes ça
ressemble beaucoup à certains nombre de
scrutins locaux ouais c'estàdire là où
il y a finalement une multiplicité
j'allais dire de chef de fil de
portertendard du PS Parti communiste des
Verts en général ça réussi plutôt bien
pour les élections locales pour les
élections européennes le mode de scrutin
étant différent jusqu'à présent la
France insoumise est très embarrassé sur
les les élections européennes parce que
les enjeux qui sont débattus l'éloignent
de son électorat traditionnel et ce qui
est très intéressant depuis les
attentats du weekend dernier c'est voir
que peut-être pour une fois pour une
élection européenne les questions de
politique étrangère de politique
internationale
seront débattus et là c'est pas la
première fois où il y a une discorde
entre LFI et les autres parties ça a été
vrai pour la guerre en Ukraine hein
souvenons-nous des positions alambiqué
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon vis-à-vis de la
Russie souvenons-nous aussi d'une
position qui est pas très claire de la
France insommise dans le conflit entre
la Chine et Taïwan et de nouveau on a
une ligne de partage et je dirais que le
point commun on peut dire c'est de
l'idéologie mais on voit bien que
derrière la matrice de la France
insoumise ce parti s'est imposé
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires de laanupes
dont on voit bien que les jours sont
quand même comptés c'est la question
traditionnelle de la France insoumise
c'est de construire son idéologie autour
d'un monde où il y aurait des dominant
et un monde où il y aurait des dominés
et c'est la grille de lecture qui est
appliqué nécessaire enfin nécessairement
immanquablement à chaque fois qu'il y a
une opposition au sein des gauches et
est-ce que c'est pas la grille de
lecture justement qui prévaut depuis
très longtemps d'ailleurs à gauche sur
ce qui se passe au proche- Orient entre
des Israéliens présentés comme des
dominés des dominants et des
Palestiniens qui sont présentés comme
des dominés absolument c'est ce qui se
passe et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il
y a un parlementaire du groupe des
insoumis Rodrigo Arenas qui a pris la
parole hier pour dénoncer cela en disant
qu'on ne peut pas choisir C on peut pas
choisir les victimes selon le camp que
l'on préfère enfin cette espèce de
dénonciation justement de ce que de de
ce de ce choix idéologique profondément
idéologique des des insoumis dans la
guerre israëlo-palestinienne dans les
tensions qu'il y a et en fait tout ce
qui est en train de se faire c'est que
cet isolement des insoumis dont vous
parlez très bien et dont Judi et Arthur
ont parlait aussi c'est-à-dire que plus
que un refus des socialistes de
participer à la nupè il y a peut-être
l'isolement des insoumis qui se sont
finalement rapprochés du NPA et qui qui
vont s'extraire eux même de cette nupess
et il va y avoir quelque chose parce
qu'il y a une sorte de flou chez les
écologistes et évidemment au partis
communiste qui vont faire que ça leur
permettra de rester avec les socialistes
et finalement ce que je présuppose c'est
que la nupesse se reformera en isolant
les insoumis qui formeront un bloc à
part et c'est puisqu'on voyait manuel
Vals cette espèce de fracture dont le
pont sera de plus en plus difficile à
franchir et c'est ce que Olivier fort a
essayé d'expliquer tout à l'heure
c'estàd qu'il ne vous voulait pas que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon porte les couleurs de
l'anupesse il voulait les reprendre à
lui et c'est sa technique depuis le
début il se dit en fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon complètement de façon
illusoire parce qu'effectivement ils
sont extrêmement faibles mais son
objectif à lui c'est de dire c'est nous
qui allons attirer les trouples de
laanupese parce que les 22 % ça n'était
pas le vote de Jean-Luc Mélenchon au
sens du vote des insoumis mais c'était
le vote de ceux qui sont allés vers le
plus fort qui était à l'époque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon oui mais enfin il y a une
réalité électorale quand même et la
réalité électorale c'est que Mélenchon
il a capté
l'électorat et sur son nom en grande
partie quand même faut pas faut pas le
nier des banlieux un électorat arabo
mususulman et cet électorat là me
semble-t-il il est quand même assez
compatible aussi
ou assez peu compatible plutôt avec
Israël est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut
considérer comme aujourd'hui au cœur du
sujet de actualité internationale oui
alors dans l'électorat dans les
électeurs de
Mélenchon à la présidentielle et au
législatif il y a cet électorat que vous
décrivez mais il y en a un autre qui est
un électorat de de de CADR moyen assez
asses diplômés de de profs un
électorat de gauche tout simplement qui
ne vient pas grâce au alors hier euh
j'aurais dit islamogauchiste de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aujourd'hui après les
déclarations de Mélenchon notamment sur
la manifestation de soutien à Israël où
il a tweeté euh vous vous l'avez
peut-être vu le CRIF à obligé euh la
France à se euh soumettre à la au S
enfin à raller le soutien à la à la
politique au gouvernement d'extrême
droite d'Israël donc c'est là on est
dans le fantasme du complot juif avec le
le CRIF qui oblige on ne sait pas
comment et le le fantasme du complot
juif c'est pas la première fois que
Mélenchon s'en prend au CRIF hein il
l'avait dit au moment où
Corbin chef des travaillistes
britanniques s'était fait éjecter de son
parti pour
antisémitisme précisément il avait écrit
sur son blog qu'on ne compte pas sur moi
euh pour les génuflexions devant les
oucases du CRF donc c'est obsessionnel
chez lui et et et parler d'un groupe qui
se trouvait le Conseil représentatif des
institutions juifes de France comme
assez influent assez puissant pour
déterminer la politique de la France
c'est un des fondements de
l'antisémitisme Arthur d'accord avec ça
complètement d'accord j'ajouterai qu'
par ailleurs depuis le mandat pour
rentrer un peu dans les détails du CRIF
de Francis Khalifa qui est le le
précédent président du CRIF il le
président a changé il y a peu le CRIF le
lui rend bien d'ailleurs hein Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la France insoumise ne sont
plus invités à ce qu' était le
rendez-vous la vitrine traditionnelle du
CRIF qui est en réalité un appel au don
principalement qui est leur dîner annuel
euh la France insoumise en est exclu au
même titre que le front devenu
rassemblement national donc en effet il
y a ce discours de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
que le CRIF a très bien compris et qui
désormais le lui rend bien en ayant
exclu Jean-Luc Mélenchon de l'arc
républicain vous savez ce ce thème très
cher à à notamment à ellisabeth bne je
voulais simplement revenir en deux mots
sur la logique dont on parlait tout à
l'heure qui est cette logique de
oppresseur opprimé dominant dominé et
cetera vous savez en informatique on
parle de langage on code dans un langage
bon donc la gauche elle code dans ce
langage là qui est le langage
intersectionnel opprimé opprimant et
puis en informatique parfois il y a des
bugs et bien la gauche aujourd'hui cette
gauche là en tout cas est confrontée à
un bug sur cette question des minorités
puisque elle a elle-même instauré une
concurrence victimaire ou prétendument
victimaire de ces minorités sur la
question homosexuelle par exemple
puisque si l'on considère que les
populations arabo-musulmanes euh en
général et qu'en l'occurrence les
Palestiniens sont des opprimés qu'en
est-il au sein de ces opprimés de ceux
qui sont eux-mêmes opprimé à savoir les
les les personnes LGBT euh dont on
entend et dont on lit des histoires
abominables hein pour ce qui concerne
euh euh territoire de Gaza euh et autres
et donc c'est là que le logiciel de
cette gauche intersectionnelle rencontre
un bug et c'est là que l'on envoie toute
l'hypocrisie et toutes les limites
surtout en réalité oui mais le le gros
bug depuis les attentats c'est que euh à
part la France insoumise personne ne
conteste qu'Israël est la victime et
d'ailleurs ça a suscité euh une
unanimité euh rare euh dans l'OP dans
l'opinion française d'abord au niveau
international ensuite et dans la classe
politique française donc ça va plus du
tout puisque normalement euh Israël
c'est l'oppresseur hm hm h oui c'est
mais je crois que la la la la la force
des des des images c'est le cas de le
dire et là a fait basculer pas mal de de
regards c'est pour ça je vous disais que
le le le le le
substrat antisémite islamuchiste qui est
de plus en plus véhiculé par Mélenchon
lui-même au sent de la France à soumise
va à mon avis réduire son
électorat à une frangeche beaucoup plus
plus étroite que les voix qu'il avait
réussi à attirer par des thèmes sociaux
par des thèmes révolutionnaires par des
thèmes de gauche traditionnel on n pas
encore de
sondage depuis les attentats contre
Israël sur les intention de vote aux
européennes
mais je pense qu'il y a fort à parier
que alors sans vouloir faire offense à
notre invité extérieur et j'en termine
par là je crois qu'il y en aura bientôt
un dans les colonnes du Figaro
alors martial fouo en guise de
conclusion sur ce sujet-là qu'on réponde
à la question initiale qui a été posée
est-ce que les partis de gouvernement à
gauche peuvent espérer avoir un avenir
et peuvent vivre sans la nupes ou
doivent sortir de la nupes oui ils
peuvent avoir un avenir combien de temps
cela prendra-t-il nul nul ne le sait
est-ce que les partis de gauche peuvent
faire mieux sans laanupè je pense que le
scrutin européen n'est pas le bon
scrutin
ça la la force la présence des partis de
gauche reconstitué euh dans l'espace
national et je rajoute deux éléments
très très très brefs on a regardé en
2022 la composition religieuse de
l'électorat des candidat euh sur
l'électorat qui se déclare sont des
enquêtes déclaratives de confession
musulmanes le premier parti des
musulmans en 2022 c'était l'abstention
premier parti ensuite le candidat
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a recueilli 40 %
j'arrondis des électeurs qui se
déclaraient
équivoté musulman et c'est quand même
une évolution parce que en 2012 François
Hollande avait eu la majorité du vote
des musulmans donc on voit bien qu'il y
a une évolution c'està dire que cette
question d'identité par rapport au
conflit
israëlo-palestinien ne suffit pas et ça
pose quand même la question est-ce que
c'est une stratégie électorale ces
déclaration euh je je je suis pas
certain que ces sorties suffisent à
rassembler ou à élargir la base
électorale euh des Français de
confessions musulmanes ça va mê ça va
même les éloigner parce qu'à mon avis
euh parmi les musulmans de France
euh ce serait une grave erreur de
considérer qu'ils sont tous antisémites
oui et c'est là où il faut regarder les
générations parce que on n' pas le même
comportement des jeunes musulmans et des
plus anciens musulans bien sûr